hello and welcome to swipe coming up the
rise of the machines are we in danger of
letting technology rule our lives
Facebook invest billions in a virtual
reality headset we get our hands on the
brand new HTC phone and we meet the
Reaper of souls in our games review here
on swype we're always looking for ways
to better ourselves so this week we
decided to take a look at the growing
trend of what's been dubbed nag tech I'm
talking about all those gadgets that
tell you what to do how to do it and
when to do it it sounds great but come
on do you really want to be bossed
around by gizmos I've been to meet one
man who swears by them forget going to
the major electronics shows if you want
to see the latest in gadgets and
wearable tech a trip to Kiran's house
might be just as insightful every day
his various devices keep him in check by
tracking his weight body fat exercise
diet calories sleep there's even one to
make sure he's standing up straight so
when I need for I slouch it'll vibrate
in my back and give me a warning on
alert to sit up straight or stand up
straight to correct my posture we can do
that right here a trend in these nag
tech devices so cool because they tell
us what to do is growing and what is it
about being now that you like so much
you know I think having a reminder we
again we you know we all really i think
we all secret life have a life coach you
guys have someone so on our shoulder
things that help us improve with using
other people's knowledge very nice one
thing these devices do they give you
more knowledge so what kinds of
knowledge are we getting won't there's
the happy fork released last year which
tells you if you're eating too quickly
by vibrating and flashing there's a
smart toothbrush that makes sure you're
cleaning your teeth properly and you
might have seen this it's called mother
it basically monitors your life via
sensors giving you all kinds of
notifications from when to take your
vitamins to warning when you're about to
run out of coffee but surely the success
of nag Tech has to depend on how much
you really want it you've ever had your
boss micromanage you or your mother's
ever told you to put out a coat because
it's cold out
side and you feel that reaction of you
know don't tell me what to do when your
freedom feels a little bit threatened
that sensation is called reactants and
it interestingly enough our gadgets can
inflict the same response if you're
already feeling reactants wait till you
hear what the future looks like when
clever tech starts to change us
physically or gets really interesting is
by by 2030 2035 we start to replace by
choice perfectly good biological organs
and parts with electronic technology so
imagine for example being able to
download a new skill over the network
download a new language because you need
a because you're traveling maybe you
swap out a perfectly good eye for an
artificial eye that gives you zoom
vision so by then maybe Karen won't need
any of his gadgets he could have details
downloaded directly to his brain but I
get the feeling he might actually miss
all that nagging Gemma Morris Sky News
you're watching swype coming up is the
latest HTC better than an iphone we take
a look at the brand new handset but
first Facebook's shelling out just over
1.2 billion pounds for the makers of the
virtual reality headset oculus rift the
rift launched just two years ago on
Kickstarter will continue to operate
independently but Facebook plans to use
it for social media so is it worth the
price tag skies Tom cheshire reports the
first time you suddenly your brains is
okay I know it's not real but I think it
is virtual reality finally made real
this is the oculus rift a virtual
reality video gaming headset Mark
Zuckerberg believes will become in his
words part of daily life for billions of
people so much so that he spent two
billion dollars acquiring the company
behind the device so what does this tell
us about Facebook's grander strategy
people have been dreaming of virtual
reality for decade previous devices have
failed to deliver what's different now
the reason why virtual reality is at
point now where where people like
Facebook up 8 they're taking notice is
it's kind of this perfect storm almost
of technology computer power
everything's coming together so you've
got processors powerful enough to create
and render realistic-looking visuals but
you've also got technology able to
provide
really slick head tracking motion
tracking and also em with like almost no
latency so what does this tell us about
Facebook's grander strategy at the
moment the the obvious applications are
sort of video gaming and that sort of
thing there will be I'm sure all sorts
of business cases in the future where
rather than looking at one screen and
you've got sort of a couple of documents
open now you'll be able to have
documents stored all over your field of
vision facebook doesn't just want to be
a social network it wants to own the
whole communication stack whether that's
messages photo sharing voice calls or
even virtual reality Tom cheshire Sky
News you're watching swype coming up we
run through this week's biggest news in
tech but first HTC had an interesting
year in 2013 at the HTC One smartphone
picked up plenty of awards but its share
of the market fell so how does the
company plan to make its new models
stand out from the crowd skies martin
stanford got his hands on the perhaps
not so snappily named HTC one m8 here it
is slightly larger than its predecessor
a whole five inches of screen here and
the design has changed a bit with the
metalwork to the aluminium edges here go
right to the edge of the gorilla glass
HTC say that presented their engineers
with some aerial problems but they've
overcome them they've left the controls
more or less where you might expect them
a rocker switch here for your volume
down the side and there's a SIM card
tray now this is a nano-sim just like an
apple iphone so that's an interesting
change every millimeter of space matters
the usual charging port is on the bottom
here and the headphone jack well that's
moved to the bottom as well now talking
of iPhones this is very much going after
that premium iphone 5 market and it's a
bigger device this is a 5s I can put
alongside and you can see in terms of
phones you get a lot more phone and a
lot more screen if you choose to go down
the HTC root HTC have gone for the
photography again they don't talk about
the number of pixels or how many
megapixel
you can cram into a camera they believe
in this technology where they've made
each pixel bigger so called ultrapixels
it's all about the size of your pixels
not how many you've got say HTC they've
continued that theme with not one but
two cameras here the camera here is
doing the photography the camera here is
doing the depth so depth information can
be recorded by this second camera
apparently and embedded in the JPEG file
so that you can do various clever
post-production tricks you can defocus a
background or d focus one person more
than another I caught up with Phil Blair
who runs HTC in Europe and put it to him
was it frustrating that whereas HTC get
a lot of accolades rivals like Samsung
tend to get the lion's share of sales to
be honest and I don't I'm not interested
in talking about me or the competition
really i think you know good for them
and what they what they've done we are
just super focused on doing what we do
which is make great phones and I said
you know we love phones and I think what
you saw with the with the HTC One in
2013 was a genuine step change we think
that we will make an even bigger step
change this year with the with the HTC
One m8 and I think I think that
competition has got something to worry
about you're watching swype coming up we
solve puzzles with Professor Layton but
first here's a roundup of anything you
might have missed over the past few days
tax relief for the UK video games
industry is finally going ahead the EU
Commission's approved the move after
months of deliberation not to mention
the years of lobbying from campaigners
before that trade body tiger says the
victory could bring 188 million pounds
of extra investment for British games
businesses between now and 2019 alone
candy crush shares crashed this week
almost a billion dollars was wiped off
their value in just a few minutes of
trading on the new york stock exchange
shares in King digital the company
behind mobile game candy crush saga
started at 22 and a half dollars but
fell to around 19 investors have been
wary of games firms with a limited range
of products king is a great and solid
business it's not a a bubble business
what I'm concerned about
it's being valued on the assumption that
it can churn out a string of hits when
it's churned out one amazing hit and a
series of other good games I mean by any
previous standards there other games
would be out liyliy good it's just that
this candy crush one is so amazing that
I think there's a danger to put stars in
people's eyes in terms of evaluation if
you've ever wanted to design a space
suit now's your chance NASA's asking the
public to pick its next one the
futuristic z2 needs an outer shell
before it's used and that's where you
come in there are three designs to pick
from biomimicry technology and trends in
society you can cast your vote online a
company founded by a wanted cyber
fugitive who's being listed on the new
zealand stock exchange with an estimated
value of more than 100 million pounds
internet fast storage company mega
limited was created by Kim calm the
founder of now closed megaupload mr.
calm was arrested with three others in
2012 for online piracy money laundering
and racketeering Google glass could be
about to go mainstream it's signed a
deal with the people behind oakley and
ray-ban so instead of looking maybe a
little bit creepy a computer on your I
could become a fashion statement at the
moment we don't know when the frames
will go on sale but it's promising
avant-garde design and staying with
Google the tech giant's taking the top
spot in this year's t3 hot 100 list it's
been recognized for being ever-present
in our lives and also at the forefront
of wearable tech with Google glass the
new HTC One m8 is the highest ranking
product on the wish list it's a great
time for gaming at the moment with new
titles coming out almost every day it
would take far too long for us to
critique all of them so we managed to
recruit luke Kamali to take us through
just a few this is the concluding
chapter to the bioshock infinite story
with second part the dlc called Barry
let's see so this puts you anyone who's
played bioshock infinite will know
Elizabeth this puts you in her shoes
back in rapture which is where the first
game was set it's an entirely new tale
setting a kind of alternate reality but
what manages to do very very cleverly
it's tied together the story of the
original BioShock with the story that
started in BioShock
it's very moving it's again very dark
very gritty and Elizabeth has been
reimagined this kind of fem a-- fatale
it's very very visually striking it's
only about five hours long but anyone
who disappoint in the first half of the
dlc won't be disappointed in this it's
much much closer to kind of what we
expect from a bioshock game notes was
ken Levine has an answered this is him
it hadn't done with bioshock it's kind
of a now-or-never if you ever want to
say goodbye to the franchise this is the
perfect way to do it joblist we launched
to a bit of a mixed reaction last year
so when the first expansion was
announced we have sold people were kind
of interested but perhaps weren't as
looking forward to as they should have
been now it's launched and for starter
has none of the issues that the original
Diablo had when it launched but also the
aesthetic is much darker the tone is
much grittier it's gotten rid of the
auction house as well which is kind of
the main problem people have the first
one because the point of it is you to
dungeon call an adventure where you
gather loot new weapons an item that was
kind of ruined by the auction house
because you could just buy whatever you
needed to why would you pay the game
that's gone it's all about the gameplay
once again the aesthetic is better than
ever before there's a new class the
Crusader which is credibly exciting you
have this massive flail and this big
shield so if you haven't played Diablo
before this is closer to the original
game so it's this is probably the best
time to jump in
so fez has been out for a long while on
other platforms including xbox and pc
but it's finally coming to PlayStation
platform so that's PS Vita ps3 and ps4
it's a really really quirky adventure
platforming game and the way it works is
you can rotate all the maps and to
create new platforms so it plays on your
sense of perception and through rotating
it you can kind of make illusion become
reality it's very very quick in how to
explain it's got unique art style it's
absolutely beautiful so if you have
missed out on it before this is the
perfect time to pick up you've got 3d s
you probably know about professor layton
and also phoenix wright ace attorney
this game brings them together for the
first time so you have some of the
puzzle solving gameplay that is in the
vessel 18 games but also all the
courtroom drama that comes from the
Phoenix Wright games they're not natural
bedfellows necessarily it's more
fanservice game but that doesn't mean
it's not a lot of fun you have crazy
characters like all of the witnesses
have nervous tic so there's a chef who
sits in the dock and every time you
catch them out on something he twitches
nervously and swings a cleaver at fish
it's quite an amusing game and you know
again as the latent series has recently
come to a close this is a good way to
say goodbye to her
that's it for this week remember you can
catch up with the breaking tech stories
all week on Sky News for ipad our
smartphone apps are sky nice calm
bye-bye